l'armé secrète arménienne menace à
nouveau la france dans un deuxième
message à l' agence france presse de
téhéran la sallaz annonce nous allons
verser le sang dans toute la france et
aux quatre coins du monde si les
sympathisants de notre organisation ne
sont pas libérés nouvelle menace donc
prise au sérieux par les autorités
françaises au lendemain des aveux du
couple du coupable de l'attentât d'orly
et de l'inculpation de 11 personnes
d'origine arménienne ce qui porte au
total avec les précédents d'attentât
contre l'ambassade de turquie par
exemple à 16 le nombre de détenus
d'origine arménienne dans les prisons
françaises
les mesures de sécurité ont donc été
annoncées par les pouvoirs publics aient
commencé d'être appliquée cela dit le
ministère de l'intérieur reste très
discret même plus que cela sur les
mesures prises comme en témoigne
l'enquète ce matin de jean-marc dubois
air france sur les champs-elysées
hier il y a eu une alerte à la bombe
aujourd'hui pas un car de police en vue
pas un seul fonctionnaire assis il n'y a
pas de voitures garées devant l' agence
une mesure de sécurité sûrement non tout
simplement des places libres
à l'intérieur de l'agencé personne non
plus pas de protection apparente
la direction d'air france précise que
des mesures de sécurité ont bien été
prises mais qu'elle perdrait toute
efficacité si elles étaient dévoilés ce
n'est pas l'avis du personnel qui a
demandé que la sécurité soit renforcée
ce matin certains employés n'ont pas
voulu revêtir leurs uniformes trop
dangereux hors lits non plus les mesures
de sécurité annoncées par le ministère
de l'intérieur ne sont pas visibles à
l'intérieur c'est la foule des grands
départs il n'y a pas de policiers
quelques panneaux ont été installés
depuis l'attentât de vendredi dernier
pour éviter une pratique courante un
passager vous propose de vous donner sa
valise car il a un excédent de poids et
vous voilà avec deux valises des
panneaux mais toujours pas de policiers
visibles tout cela n'a pas l'air de
convaincre certains passagers qui
voudraient peut-être moins de discrétion
et plus de présence policière 115
aéroports qui sont très simples et
d'autres qui le sont moins
et très sincèrement je pense que les
aéroports français sont pas les bruits
pourtant il y avait ce matin à orly
quelques passagers al'allure un peu
stricte peut-être une des mesures prises
par la police au ministère de
l'intérieur on se refuse à dévoiler les
nouvelles dispositions discrétion et
efficacité oblige la seule mesure
apparente ce policier devant la turkish
airlines mais la police a d'autres
moyens qui ne sont visibles ni des
passagers ni des journalistes des moyens
discret mais très efficace assure-t-on
au ministère de l'intérieur